HE MUST COMMUNICATION.
>> Brian: A FOUL TO GIVE.
TWO TIME-OUTS, BOSTON JUST USED
THEIR LAST TIME-OUT.
HERE WE GO, TATUM, GIANNIS
SWITCHES, TATUM TO
ANTETOKOUNMPO, THE SUPERSTAR
STEPS BACK, THREE ON THE WAY --
OH, IT BANKS IN.
TATUM OVER
GIANNIS, AND BOSTON BY TWO, WITH
0.4 SECONDS REMAINING.
>> Chris: IT TURNED INTO A
ONE-ON-ONE GAME, GOING UP
AGAINST THE BEST OFFENSIVE
PLAYER ON BOSTON, TAKING THEIR
TIME, GETTING THE BEST SHOT
AVAILABLE, HIS PATENTED MOVE.
WE HAVE SEEN TATUM DO IT, IN AND
OUT, LEFT DRIBBLE, STEP BACK TO
THE LEFT, ANGLE, AND YEAH, THE
BANK'S OPEN.
YOU CAN
OUT-OF-BOUNDS.
THE LOSER WILL PLAY THE WINNER
OF THE 9-10 MATCH UP THE WINNER
OF THAT GAME HANDS ON THE
POSTSEASON AS WELL.
SO IF YOU FINISH SEVENTH OR
EIGHTH, ONE WIN IT'SST THE
CAVS.
TATUM TO THE HOLE.
>> Austin: YES, INDEED MEANS SO
OBVIOUSLY TO BOTH OF THEM.
IF YOU'RE FRANK VOGEL, HE'S ONLY
ONE IN THIS POSITION, YOU'VE GOT
TWO OF THE TOP TEN PLAYERS IN
THE GAME GETTING READY TO COME
BACK.
THAT'S WHY I WOULDN'T BE
SWEATING WHERE THEY ARE RIGHT
NOW.
>> Reggie: ONCE HE GOT INTO THE
LANE, ALL THE PURPLE JERSEYS
AROUND HIM, HAULED OFF A
A REBOUND TAKEN OVER THE TOP TU
AN OFFENS
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL BE JAYSON
TATUM.
12 SECONDS ON
HE GOES OUT TO THE BASKET.
TATUM.
AND A FOUL.
HE GOES OUT TO THE BASKET.
WASHINGTON TAKES A TIMEOUT.
AND A FOUL.
A BIG-TIME SHOT BY TATUM.
WASHINGTON TAKES A TIMEOUT.
THEY GOT THE POST UP.
A BIG-TIME SHOT BY TATUM.
IT IS WHAT HE WANTED.
THEY GOT THE POST UP.
HE GETS THE CONTACT AND THE
IT IS WHAT HE WANTED.
FOCUS IN THE FINISH.
HE GETS THE CONTACT AND THE
JAYSON TATUM PUTS THE CELTICS
FOCUS IN THE FINISH.
UP BY 1. A CHANCE FOR MELLI, AN
ONE MORE STOP TO PUT THIS ONE
AWAY.
>> Doris: ALL OF THOSE GUYS, 25
AND YOUNGER.
>> Mark: THEIS TO INBOUND FOR
THE CELTICS.
IT MUST BE SUNDAY BECAUSE JAYSON
TATUM LOOKS VERY ROUTINE ABOUT
WHAT HE JUST DID.
>> Doris: BACK TO BACK BUCKETS.
GAME HANGING IN THE BALANCE.
YOUR TEAM HAS GIVEN UP A
24-POINT LEAD.
JOSH HART MAKES YOU CATCH THE
BALL AT HALF-COURT.
YOU ARE UNDER DURESS OF THE SHOT
CLOCK, AND AN EXCELLENT
INDIVIDUAL PLAYER.
HE MAKES YOU PUT IT ON THE DECK,
AND MAKE MAYBE THE TOUGHEST SHOT
IN BASKETBALL.
A FLOATER ON THEOP.
10 SECONDS TO PLAY.
7, 6.
.
THE PISTONS AND CELTICS SPLIT
HERE IN LITTLE CAESARS ARENA
INTO GAMES THAT HAVE GOT TO THE
WIRE.
GREG: WELL, MILK THE CLOCK.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY DID.
NOW YOU GIVE IT TO YOUR OPTION
ONE, 1A.
GOOD BALLHANDLING ABILITY TO
CREATE HIS OWN STUFF.
THAT IS WHEN JAYSON TATUM WAS
GA.
TOO STRONG, TOO SAVVY.
HE'S GOING TO DRAW A FOUL.
>> Mike: THERE'S GRANT FOR IRVI.
5.8 SECONDS REMAINING IN THE
PERIOD.
HERE COMES TATUM.
LOOKING.
BLOCKED BY DURANT
>> Ryan: WE TALKED ABOUT IT
EARLIER, DORIS, JEFF TEAGUE HAS
NOT NECESSARILY BEEN A
OFFENSIVE REBOUND.
FEEDS WILLIAMS FOR THE FINISH.
PAYTON PRITCHARD COMING UP WITR
THE PUT-BACK.
EIGHT POINTS NOW FOR WILLIAMS
OFF THE BENCH.
>> Mark: THE FUNNY THING, COACH,
WE'VE SEEN GUYS AND WE KNOW THAT
THEY JUST HAPPEN TO BE WIRED
BECAUSE THEY WERE TALKING MORES
THOMPSON.
YOU GOT TO COMMIT TO TWO GUYS
AND ALLOW THEM TO GAIN A RHYTHM.
>> Mike: BLOCKING FOUL CALLED ON
LeBRON JAMES.